I have had to have it issues where I go to the bathroom, but be of all day.
So, multiple bulwavids per day. Could this come from the black-sav-blood route,
that black paste-bundered, black-sav-blood route capsules, or the eluvia imbued,
that I have been on? Maybe because I also take three to four of the
atri-alo, which is cape-alo a day. So, the black-sav-blood route, either black-sav-blood route,
or the eluvia imbued will cause a person to have, you know, multiple bulwavids per day.
Of course, any supplement that a person could take, if you had a sensitivity to the capsule or something
like that, that could cause some issues, but either one of those products would cause bulwavids.
The atri-alo is a cape-alo. The only reason why a person would take that aloe is to have
bulwavids. So, that isn't a nutritive product. So, the atri-alo is not something you take because
I'm deficient in aloe. It's not something you take to help heal my gut. So, there's different types
of aloe vera. So, an aloe vera product like a liquid aloe could be very healing to your gut,
or if you took an aloe vera leaf and you put some of that, you know, literally slitted open
and put some of that in your smoothie every day. That could be very healing to your gut. Cape-alo
is not consumed as a supplement to help heal the gut. It's solely consumed as a supplement
to help you have a bulwavid. So, the only time I tell people to take that is if you're constipated.
So, if you're taking three or four of those a day on a regular basis, that's why you're having
the bulwavids. So, yes, so, the discontinue that or drop it down to one a day and try to make sure
you're having a bulwavid every day, but you certainly, that's something that a person typically needs to
take on a daily basis.